the search is on this evening for the
person who shot two people on the 215 in
the southern part of the valley in a
road rage incident one person died
another in the hospital police say it
all happened in the south valley on the
2 15 between warm springs and las vegas
boulevard about 2 30 this morning
joe mohler live near where that happened
with what we know so far joe
brian talk about a frightening situation
right now police are looking for a gray
four-door sedan that had four people in
it it is believed that road rage led to
the shooting here on the 215 that took
the life of the driver and left his
passenger in critical condition
a portion of the 215 near the airport
was closed during rush hour monday
lieutenant david valenta tells 8 news
now two cars possibly chasing each other
in the eastbound lanes were involved two
cars
would be side by side
unknown arguments started at which time
one of the vehicles fired rounds into
our victim vehicle
the victim driver was struck causing him
to crash his vehicle into the center
divider the driver died and his
passenger taken to the hospital she
suffered critical injuries police said
the couple is in their 20's it's not
clear right now what led up to the
deadly shooting
police are asking if you were on the 2
15 this morning between las vegas
boulevard and warm springs about 2 30.
if you have any information if you saw
anything abnormal any cars possibly
chasing each other anything that might
help police you're asked to give them a
call reporting live joe mohler live
local now